- Thank you so much, thank you, thank you.
(upbeat music)
- My name's Brianna and
I'm a former pageant girl.
- I'm Rebecca Margaret
and I'm a pageant girl.
- Hi, I'm Jarry and I've
competed in one pageant.
- My name is Emily and
I'm a former pageant girl.
- I feel people would ask is
there a height requirement.
- How expensive it is,
just really expensive.
- Are pageant girls mean?
- Or like the weird stuff,
like flippers and butt glue.
- For the most part it is something to do
with community service.
- Who you are as a person.
- Academic achievement.
- Your beauty.
- Sometimes swimsuit.
- The way that you can present yourself.
- Answer questions like what
would I do to save the world
and stuff like that.
- Oh, that's a tough one.
- I don't think that pageants
are intended to be sexist,
I think they're intended to be empowering
and show that beauty is not
just about physical beauty,
but also you are on a
stage and you are sometimes
being objectified.
- If you look this way in a swimsuit
and the other girl
doesn't then unfortunately
you are more likely to win
just based on your looks.
- I think pageants may
be a little bit sexist
in that they only recognize
a very narrow view of beauty,
but I don't think there's anything wrong
with the women that do do pageants
and recognize for themselves
that they are beautiful,
and that's okay to show.
- The ones that I've
competed in have been mostly
about my community service
and about my education,
not about the way that I look.
- I think beauty pageants boost
self-confidence if you win
and if you don't win then
you'll be comparing yourself
to the person who did.
- It is a little bit hard to be surrounded
by gorgeous women and not feel like
there might be something
wrong with your face.
I'm fine now.
- I came in to beauty
pageants after being bullied
and it really helped me
grow my confidence back
and believe in myself again.
- I always got first
runner ups so I don't know
if I can answer that correctly.
- I guess you just have to
impress the panel of judges
on pretty much every single category.
- It's all about your
package and who you are
and what you're selling the judges.
- I would say 80% of a beauty pageant
is what you're wearing,
your walk, your hair,
your makeup, and the
other 20% is your answers
to the questions that they ask you.
- They can be beneficial
depending on why you enter.
If you're entering to gain self-confidence
or because you like to, you
know, dress up and have fun
then it can be beneficial to you,
but not if you're the kind of person who
will really have the self-esteem
hit if they don't win.
- I won a lot of self-confidence
after winning that pageant
and also I won a scholarship.
- The pageants taught me how
to do a really mean catwalk
so they can benefit you.
- Oh, a pageant walk
has a lot of confidence,
you have to strut your
stuff, you have to be elegant
and poised and just look really graceful.
- You are always supposed
to be facing the judges
and the audience, just
walk with confidence.
- You're walking very balanced
and you have your shoulders
back and your chest high.
- And just remember to relax your arms,
you don't want like T-Rex arms.
Remember to make eye
contact with the judges,
show them that you're
confident and like super cute.
(upbeat music)